real quickly sean payton on the post
drew brees era peyton talked about that
earlier today here he is talking about
the quarterbacks not named drew brees
who will be competing to be the starter
in 2021
and it's coming now
here it is
the profile doesn't change
certainly
we're mindful of our depth at each
position
you know we're currently in our final
board readings on the defensive side of
the ball
um
yeah i think
relative to that position though it
still stays the same and and traits that
we're looking for
you know i i don't
i don't think it's a must position we
feel like we've got
real good players in the building
hey i know this whatever sean payton's
thinking about doing in the draft
especially at quarterback he ain't going
to tell us he's not going to give us
anything that we could sink our teeth
into and the bottom line is we know they
like taysom hill we know like jameis
winston i don't know why they'd be
looking at drafting a quarterback but
four years ago they were ready to pull
the trigger at number 11 on patrick
mahomes before they got jumped by the
chief so if there's a guy that he loves
number one he's not going to tell us and
number two
he's he'll be ready to move if he feels
like he has the opportunity to do so
i just have so much faith in sean payton
and what he can do i think he's the best
offensive coach in the league and has
been for a really long time and i think
he'll make this work with these two guys
and i like what they've done post drew
brees right they've signed both of these
guys uh
to taysom's case it was a two-year deal
that expires after this season and
jameis they gave him a one-year deal so
if neither of these guys works out there
they're not in a position
like the eagles were like the rams were
like other teams were that you're trying
to get rid of a high-priced guy right
they can go out and they can trade for
one of the quarterbacks who we know is
going to become available uh desean
watson or if aaron rodgers becomes
available or if russell wilson's on the
block they can go out and try to get one
of those guys i would have loved to have
seen tom brady this year if he had been
in free agency he could have ended up in
new orleans as drew brees replacement
instead of going to tampa if it was a
year later than what it was but i trust
sean payton to find a quarterback if
it's not one of these guys then after
this season they'll find a quarterback
somewhere whether it's in a trade or
whether it's in the draft next year but
i think he'll find his quarterback
sooner rather than later mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports